[Musique]
cela fait 6 mois que le Président de la
République a été réélu depuis aucune
réforme d'ampleur dont le pays a
pourtant un grand besoin n'a été lancé
depuis la crise des gilets jaunes
Emmanuel Macron nous a habitué à
l'inaction désormais à l'Assemblée
nationale ils ne dispose que d'une
majorité relative c'est à la fois une
chance pour faire avancer les réformes
qui sont indispensables mais c'est aussi
une très lourde responsabilité pour les
républicains qui sans tarder ont fait
des propositions utiles aux Français
utiles au pays les républicains
disposent aujourd'hui de près de 200
parlementaires à l'Assemblée nationale
au Sénat et à l'Union européenne grâce à
leur action ils ont pu faire plier le
gouvernement et obtenir des concessions
qui vous sont utiles qui sont utiles à
tous les Français j'en citerai quelques
exemples tout d'abord la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires mais aussi la
possibilité de convert les RTT en
salaire la baisse de 30 centimes du
litre de carburant ou encore la
déconjugualisation de la location adulte
handicapée
aux valeurs du travail du mérite et aux
valeurs aussi d'ordre de sécurité de
justice je me suis engagé parce que les
républicains défendent une valeur
cardinale un idéal de société qui est la
liberté et c'est cette idéal que j'ai
envie de défendre chez les républicains
être adhérents les républicains c'est
aimer la France c'est le seul parti
vraiment de droite pour moi ce qui est
nécessaire aujourd'hui dans notre pays
c'est d'avoir un parti qui défend les
valeurs du travail du respect de la
nation qui défend le mérite aussi
pourquoi adhérer aux républicains et
bien d'abord on a adhérent aux
républicains vous allez pouvoir
participer à l'élection du futur
président de notre mouvement vous aurez
votre voix à apporter vous aurez votre
mot à dire ensuite parce que dans chaque
territoire de notre pays il existe une
fédération une fédération LR qui est
prête à vous accueillir recueillir votre
avis vos propos vos suggestions votre
analyse du moment et qui pourra les
faire valoir auprès de vous dirigeants
les républicains c'est le seul parti qui
est présent comme ça dans tous les
territoires et c'est une vraie force qui
qui est un gage de sérieux et
de défense de tous les intérêts publics
c'est avoir des des convictions très
fortes
il y a une vision qui est sur le moyen
et sur le long terme aujourd'hui on est
on a une nouvelle génération qui
commence à émerger et on est là en fait
pour défendre nos idées pour défendre
notre futur on peut encore à des riches
que 3 novembre pour choisir le prochain
président de conseil politique
aujourd'hui la droite n'est représentée
ou du moins la droite républicaine n'est
représentée que par les républicains et
donc j'invite tous ceux qui souhaitent
participer à la fois la reconstruction
de la droite mais aussi à la
reconstruction de la France de s'engager
aux républicains le seul parti de droite
républicaine adhérer aux républicains
c'est tout d'abord participé de façon
active à la vie de notre mouvement
c'est rencontrer d'autres personnes
échanger débattre c'est aussi participer
à l'élaboration des choix stratégiques
de notre
mouvement c'est ensuite faire pression
sur le gouvernement plus nous serons
nombreux et plus nous avons de chances
d'être entendus de ce gouvernement afin
de le pousser à agir c'est enfin préparé
l'avenir adhérer aux républicains c'est
se placer dans une perspective de
lendemain où nous pourrons revenir aux
responsabilités nous avons besoin de
VOUS adhérer maintenant aux républicains
[Musique]